what's going on guys this is rob and
it's snowing here in northern colorado
the worst snow we've had in about five
or six years so got about a foot and a
half on the ground so far and then it's
supposed to keep on snowing into
midnight so uh yeah slow-moving storm
just hammering on us so here's the thing
as always we have to preface this by
saying that this is leet stuff so
we don't really have anything to
indicate that it's actually true but a
document has surfaced out there on the
internet basically telling us how long
the different members of the cast of
doctor strange two are supposed to
appear in the movie at the same time
also just kind of telling us who this
cast is now again
i am not taking this as an absolute so
it could be this is entirely debunked
right but this in particular came from
moth culture which i don't know how many
of you guys follow them on twitter but
they have some pretty good leaks that
come out from time to time so here's the
thing right there are some names that
stand out to me right names we already
know doctor strange wanda maximoff
america chavez wong christine palmer
baron mordo we already kind of knew
about these people being in this movie
whether it was from the trailer or the
fact that like it's a dr strange film so
there's no reason to believe they
wouldn't be there
there have also been rumors circulating
around that peggy carter is supposed to
be in doctor strange too of course we
also have the rumors about like charles
xavier and i don't even really know if
peggy carter and professor x are really
rumors so much is just things we know
are going to happen they just haven't
officially been confirmed by marvel yet
but regardless of how you slice it
people like loki iron man reed richards
rintro we already knew about quicksilver
magic jean grey these are things that
are really really interesting here right
uh the names being here makes sense
because again something that we've
reiterated here over and over and over
again is that from where i'm standing
doctor strange too is going to
consolidate the multiverse and basically
mama's going to pick and choose the
things they want right it's very crisis
on infinite earth and that's one of the
things to keep in mind when it comes to
doctor strange too one of the things
that people are doing is they're looking
at this movie from the perspective of
the rest of the marvel cinematic
universe but remove that for a second
remove the marvel cinematic universe and
basically compare it to the events of
what is in effect the crisis on infinite
earth's story so here's the idea behind
crisis on evidence so you guys never
read that story from dc comics it's a
landmark story the overall gist here is
that prior to this to this particular
story to to the first crisis event you
had dc's multiverse right originally
introduced in flash of two worlds and
over the course of 20 years it just
became ridiculously complex so much so
that people who were getting into dc
comics didn't know where to start and so
in the 80s dc was just like rebooted all
and so what they did is they had this
great big huge calamity where in effect
the multiverse was destroyed and in the
aftermath of that came something called
new earth and they basically retold
origins for characters right give them
like updated origins switch things
around so like barry allen the flash had
basically died he was replaced by wally
west who was aged up just things along
those lines right now i'm not saying
that the marvel cinematic universe is
going to be going through and like
giving everybody new origins but the
form and function of the original crisis
event works here right the form and
function of crisis on infinite earth
works when you compare it to doctor
strange two because if we're if we
really are getting the x-men right i
mean like literally right here it says
jean grey is going to appear for like
three and a half minutes right the human
torch is supposedly there for one and a
half minutes now i'm not saying that the
the doctor strange two is going to like
basically reboot the mcu insofar as like
everybody gets brand new origins what i
am saying is the same thing i've been
saying that the movie is going to give
us this great big huge multiversal
concept and then basically start pulling
all the stuff the marvel cinematic
universe wants to keep into the mcu now
maybe they'll get new origins but by and
large i would argue there's a really
good chance that they won't right that
will basically get all these kind of
characters that we've seen over the
years right so like the original
fantastic four team from like the early
2000s films will get like the x-men and
stuff like that so that is anything it's
basically a refresher right so people
are just like oh i remember them their
story was what was their story again and
they they figured they basically figured
out on their own right you see like the
original fantastic four which
fingers crossed
will have chris evans
as as johnny storm the human torch which
would be fantastic right but like people
will recall those films and those origin
stories and then when the time comes
when marvel's like hey everybody we're
rebooting the fantastic four it's less
like work they have to do right like
with spider-man i mean it's one of those
things like when the spider-man movie
kicked off when we first saw spider-man
homecoming you guys remember all the
memes and everything you know and all
the videos right you know like like
kevin feige talks about you know
spider-man homecoming you know when it's
that spanish video where where's all the
subtitles like we're going to reboot him
again you know cash sean being his uncle
ben it's the thing people didn't want
right people were like we don't want to
see uncle ben die again or anything like
that it turned out that like homecoming
far from home and no way home were
basically just a new origin for tom
holland spider-man in the mcu right it
was basically on me who died who played
the role of uncle ben but going into it
it could have entirely been the case
that like uncle ben just died off camera
right he died before the movie started
and the last thing he told peter is with
great power must come great
responsibility and dunzo right like
you're off to the races and so it'd be
very easy if we get a kind of refresher
on the fantastic four we get a refresher
on the x-men if for from no other
perspective than just seeing them again
and then being reminded oh i remember
that team and all that kind of stuff
that when the time comes when they give
us a fantastic four movie they don't
have to show the ship going into space
and they don't have to show them getting
cosmic rays and stuff like that right
they just kind of show the fantastic
four operating as a team there's a good
chance we'll get that but it gives them
the opportunity to effectively skim over
those origin stories and so that's why
like if you look at this list and if
this list is actually accurate it stands
to reason that the characters we're
getting will all be appearing around the
same time and together as a unit so for
example iron man loki and reed richards
all appear for about the same amount of
time i mean i guess reed richards
appears for like four seconds less
supposedly but i know it's four seconds
right and then you get charles xavier
for six minutes and 45 seconds and so
what this does is it really lends
credence to the idea that the rumors
about the illuminati are true right that
like wouldn't it be interesting if in
the aftermath of the loki tv series that
loki flees into the multiverse the
multiverse is a big place right that is
ever expanding universes are crossing
over it's absolutely chaotic i mean i
have to believe that trying to find
someone in the multiverse would be like
trying to find someone you know here on
earth in the midst of some kind of
global calamity where all forms of
communication cease to exist right like
some kind of emp goes off that basically
destroys the ability for cell phones or
any kind of phones to work right
internet doesn't work or anything like
that how in the world could you possibly
find somebody right it's like trying to
find a needle in a stack of needles and
so it would be intriguing if along the
way he stumbles across the illuminati
right and so when doctor strange goes
and is brought before that team loki's
there now it's also entirely possible
it's not the the tom hiddleston loki we
know it's a variant of tom hiddleston's
loki that's possible as well one of the
things to keep in mind is that assuming
this whole idea of the illuminati is
true and based on the things that we've
seen introduced into the multiverse
they're borrowing heavily from jonathan
hickman in a lot of ways and one of the
things we've talked about here is that
in hickman's avengers and new avengers
run that when you saw reed richards
creating the bridge basically a window
to other universes in order to figure
out why the multiverse was collapsing
the illuminati members of other worlds
or other universes consisted of familiar
faces that we just hadn't seen united on
a singular team that's one of the things
to bear in mind is that anything is
possible here and so while it may not be
the loki we know it may be the loki that
we do know and tom hiddleston stumbled
across them and that they're all
basically trying to either understand
what's going on or because loki told
them the events that transpired at the
end of season one they're aware of
what's going on and they're trying to
mount some kind of a of a rebel force
right some kind of a resistance force
against like the tsa and uh and and kane
the conqueror because wouldn't it be
really really interesting if doctor
strange two follows up after the events
of season one with loki and that what we
actually have going on out there right
now is a war between like king the
conqueror and the tsa and like what is
in effect the rebel alliance from star
wars right just kind of a ragtag band of
people taking pot shots where they can
and just trying to survive to live
another day right like like the the the
what is it the resistance forces of
humanity in like the terminator movies
right wouldn't it be cool if that's what
was going on out there we just don't
know because
the multiverse is a huge place of which
we have very little understanding
according to doctor strange
so those kinds of things are possible
here and so while again this list is
really just sort of a list that's out
there and that there's nothing to really
indicate that it's an actual credible
real leak right a reveal of information
that exists that that's part of the mcu
the timing of a lot of these things
makes sense right supposedly sylvie is
in the movie for two minutes it's a
great way to explain one of two things
that either she was subjugated by cain
the conqueror when he essentially
arrived after the death of immortus and
he was like serve me or die and because
she just wanted to live she ended up
serving him or because of the fact that
he was like i can i can give you back
the life you wanted right we can find
the universe that you came from because
the multiverse is coming back now and
even if we can't find that exact one we
can find something similar to it and so
she's working alongside him tentatively
all the while unaware of the fact that
that he's gonna betray her or he just
killed her and that two-minute scene
that we get is literally her being
killed at the hands of cain the
conqueror and being like oh my god i
really should have listened to a mortise
because you know now i'm dead right you
know there's something along those lines
right it's just enough time to get an
answer to the question what in the heck
happened to her the believability of
some of the people on this list iliana
rasputin magic she's a magic wielder
right so in marvel comics those guys who
don't know how that works you have a
kind of loose affiliation of people who
can use magic they're not really a team
per se but they do hang out at this bar
that only people who can practice magic
can actually access right so you've got
like doctor strange you got brother
voodoo you've got damon hellstrom the
scarlet witch and you've got ileana
rasputin ileana rasputin's ability to
manipulate magic is a little different
from what you normally see doctor
strange or wanda maximoff do and she
really derives a lot of her power from
like the dimension of limbo and one of
the things that's kind of interesting to
toy with here is that perhaps that's
where the illuminati you're operating
out of limbo is technically a place that
kind of exists outside of existence
there's true limbo and then there's the
pocket dimension of limbo right so the
pocket dimension of limbo in marvel
comics is like a closet in your house
right like it's part of the space in
which you dwell it's part of the
universe and every universe has its own
version of the dimension of limbo then
there's true limbo right like just out
there in the middle of nowhere we
largely could have assumed that that was
the place where immortus or the one like
he who remains if you want to call him
out uh where he existed but then of
course we found out at the end of loki
he's just at the end of time so he's not
really in true limbo which is where a
mortise resided in marvel comics so it's
entirely possible that like true limbo
is a place that exists out there and
that's where the illuminati are
stationed at because it's the one place
kang can't access because it just it
exists outside of his purview right it's
outside of his jurisdiction or perhaps
he doesn't even know it's there maybe
it's a place that iliana created right
we have we have no real idea i mean it
is possible and that would be kind of
the cool thing it is possible in that
scene when when like the door opens and
you've got like doctor strange standing
there uh with i think america chavez and
i also want to say uh wanda that like
you see like all those buildings out
there floating around and stuff like
that it's entirely possible that's limbo
and that the ability to access limbo is
like you know what is it what jack
sparrow said and pirates of the
caribbean it's a place that can never be
found except by those who already know
where it is right as weird and
mysterious as that phrase is
but that's entirely possible here so
there are you know these characters are
believable the you know some of them i
kind of have a hard time wrapping my
head around like maria rambo captain
marvel i don't know exactly how she's
gonna tie into this it would make sense
that she could potentially be a member
of the illuminati that's out there black
bolt could possibly be the same way
spider-man there's been rumors out there
in saying he's supposed to be a part of
the movie we don't know exactly what
role he would play ghost rider may also
be a part of the illuminati as well so
you know again like if the main focus of
the mcu with regards to doctor strange
too is to basically have this movie be a
pitch to us as a viewer and say hey guys
wouldn't you be excited to see the x-men
and the fantastic four appear in the mcu
maybe even john krasinski as reed
richards then it would make more sense
that like charles xavier this alternate
reality version of iron man rumored to
be played by tom cruise reed richards
who supposedly is going to be played by
john krasinski that they would have more
screen time right iron man makes sense
because it's iron man right i mean it's
the it's the face of the mcu right i
mean it's the most popular character the
marvel cinematic universe has introduced
which is kind of weird you'd think it'd
be spider-man but i would argue that
iron man is more popular than spider-man
in the marvel cinematic universe because
it all started with him right nostalgia
is a hell of a drug but let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
section right i mean this list of names
the people on it do you think this is a
this is a practical reliable list do you
think the numbers add up or you kind of
like somebody out there is just trolling
everyone
let me know what you guys think down in
the comment section thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace